what's up Wolfgang so last week Marvel
did something crazy and I wanted to wait
a few days to avoid all potential
spoilers for people but seeing as how
Marvel released their own video spoiling
what happened in the title I figured
it's time to do my own so Marvel killed
off Thanos and the very first issue of
infinity Wars prime number one they
killed Thanos so Marvel told everybody
that this was the Summer of Secrets and
apparently they were right giving us a
completely new story and starting that
story out by killing Thanos the writers
said that they did not take killing
Thanos very lightly but they also said
that it's a very integral part of the
storyline as you can see here this is
just the first issue of a 25 issue saga
and it's a really interesting saga
it has our hero starting off with all of
the Infinity stones it has Adam warlock
starting off with a soul stone Turk
Barrett starting off with the mind stone
Drax starting off with the Power Stone
Black Widow with the space stone Doctor
Strange with the time stone of course
and Captain Marvel with the reality
stone and this first issue we are
introduced to a new mysterious character
who is referred to as Requiem I'll talk
more about this character Requiem and
who I think she is I do think it's a she
in the next video I do on this which
will be an overview of infinity wars
prime which is the first issue of this
new saga so if you do not have the
comics and you don't plan on buying them
all make sure you're subscribed to my
channel to get updates on the new videos
that I do on the infinity Wars saga so
they introduced this new character
Requiem and right away she kills Thanos
there's a lot more to this very first
issue besides the death of Thanos but
obviously that being a huge part of the
storyline going forward it's just super
crazy to think that and the very first
issue that we got they kill off Thanos
so it seems like it's going to be just a
crazy saga full of twists and shocks and
surprises so I'm really looking forward
to the next issue coming out which will
be infinity Wars number 1
comes out next month so again I will be
going over each issue as they come out
so if you don't follow the comics but
want to know the story be sure to
subscribe to my channel as always please
hit that like button and of course hit
me with your thoughts on this brand new
saga and the death of Thanos in the
comments below thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
you